what's happening reject nation greg and
john here today we are gonna watch
arcane episode three leave a like leave
a damn like
and then subscribe and click that
notification bell you get notified when
our reaction for episode four is up as
well thank you so much everyone who
joined our patreon page just to watch a
long arcane with us that's what we do
there full length watch along we sync up
with the time code for the show or over
at our patreon page over there we cover
a bunch of shows where at the same tier
you get the option for both reaction
highlights and watch along included
lastly thank you to the boys at prepper
prepper prepper for editing down these
highlights for us let's get to that shot
[Music]
there's this
thing
[Music]
you could pass a lifetime without ever
facing a choice like that but it changes
you forever i thank you
friend
in the last episode i was gonna joke
about the next one having a prologue set
in the water because the first episode's
like fire and smoke in the second
episode is snow and sleet and here we
are in water my god very elemental
you're carrying this that's right next
episode it's going to begin underground
in the earth
now the next one's in the air
mislead protect the family what are you
what is happening oh
he's gonna take that oh he's taking the
stand huh
oh no
why
it's the only way
what's happening
oh hell no are they starting a riot
right now
[Music]
no
oh deckard must be losing
i love blonde boy right yeah
old rivals you never did know when to
walk away
wait
damn
this wasn't the deal
deal's changed
[Music]
oh
[Music]
he was like my favorite character no
oh man
ways to make the world a better place
this hextech dream of yours
has the potential to do that
our hextech dream kiss come on i don't
kiss by the end of the episode i'm gonna
riot
what about vander
they took them
where
so is vander's still alive it could be
oh my god he's still alive
it's like i don't
welcome to hell
do you even remember
i trusted you
and you betrayed me
oh
[Music]
oh
yeah oh no
so they're not really injecting
something that's creating it's enhancing
or igniting something within them i
guess the way he keeps talking about it
sounds like a works off some gene in you
that you already possess yeah so maybe
everybody reacts a little differently to
it or something
willing to risk exile for your endeavor
that's quite the conviction the
counselor wait a minute
you got spunk
who took vander i don't know but i need
to help him we're going with you
whatever killed bento
was like nothing i've ever seen it tore
him apart you're not doing this alone vi
oh
if they come for you
take this and run
wherever you are light it up and i'll
find you i promise
oh you used your magic [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
no
what have you done
oh thank god
oh no
[Music]
stop blowing [ __ ] up i know guys come on
oh damn no they reversed it
oh not a good reversal how did you get
in there's guards everywhere
it was easy we found an open window and
oh god
it's a trap have you heard kuruma
vander the coward fled town with his
children
and they were never seen again
let's see what this [ __ ] does
[Music]
fine
it's on a step up palette your grip on
camera perspective homie man
a plus yeah
oh yeah so i'm talking about nice
sharokina
yes
wow
wow wow it's like a zombie hulk yeah
yeah
like a resident monster huh
oh
oh
boy
this is not what piltover's future looks
like my dear
boys that's for the council to decide
council come to this room
don't run out of juice
wow
disintegrating
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's like she's floating yeah
floating in water
my god it's full of stars does she have
any idea what she did
not really
she just knew they would go bang
what
what
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
no oh
oh man
would some of that
juice get in him though yeah i could
just take some yeah
logan this
get it do it
let's do it
oh my god
it is like the abomination
too much i think he he od'd on that
[Laughter]
which i care about her
oh my goodness
did you see me my monkey bomb finally
worked
you did this
oh jesus
oh jesus
oh [ __ ]
no no no no
no no no no no
why did you do this
i didn't
i was saving you
something oh they wanted to help
[Laughter]
oh man
oh man
this
is so bad
[Music]
oh no
i'll kill you if he hits you
come on
let's go
it was smart to use chlorophyll
all you guys made it out
she left me she is not my sister anymore
oh
what is happening
we will show them all
[Music]
two
i wonder how much we get wrong for
predicting just because we haven't
played the game
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow tower of terror
this is that rare animated show where
you feel like there's a physical camera
there all the time like doing all this
camera work man
wow that was
that was epic something else yeah that
was just so devastating there's like
that whoever plays powders i'm like wow
this really feels like a little gross
i just wanted to hug her
i was like i want to hold you right now
i feel so bad for you
like she really thought she was like
like when she had a gift that was
bestowed upon her by chance
and that she was using it to rescue her
friends and she could finally prove to
all them that she was valuable
and then damage
because i was like well
she they would have all died right i
thought like they didn't really have a
fighting chance but
i guess when he broke out
vander when they jumped through the wall
that
i don't know they could have they've
done the parkour the first episode they
had they probably could have found a way
to get to the ground safely
still though that was uh that was so
so damn devastating oh my god i really
wanted i don't think i've ever had that
response to an animated character in my
life
of like i wish you were a real person
that i could hold right now
so sorry wow i understand what you were
trying to do yeah
because i thought she would because the
show has you going to thinking she's
probably going to do something like
[ __ ] she's going to be she's going to
be the hero yeah the show has you
thinking that i mean i i don't know what
jane like what her character is i've
heard the name jinx turned around before
so i'm assuming when she called her jinx
i got slightly pulled out like oh she
jinxed
my mind went there yeah um
but when uh as i i don't know
the characters and the who who's even in
the game and who just made up for this
show all right like so
um
so it actually actually makes it more
exciting for us because we don't know
how any of this will go yeah you can
just get sucked straight into the drama
and enjoy that
what's that and the majesty of
storytelling well this was like beyond
cinematic and it really had it was so
incredibly personal from beginning to
end like it had such a bleak stark
opening
when everyone just died the freaking
nice cop lady even she's she's just like
the culture's like but she's dead
his bodies are being benzo's taken out
like this i i we all knew a collapse was
coming that's what we kept saying yeah
but i did not anticipate like oh this is
all going to start just within with
everybody it's not like cities are
falling right away it's just characters
are going to start dying all right
well what's so great is they've really
drawn the situation to feel alive in the
sense that like you have a bunch of
people acting on a bunch of different
motivations and getting in each other's
way and complicating all sorts of things
and and this is a great example of that
it's like you know while vander's got
one way of looking at things and while
violet is trying to turn herself in then
you've got um you know the the you know
villainous guy with the serums coming
out and exacting his plan and there's so
much great overlap that leads to
just like the grayness and the muddiness
and the desperation of these situations
and yeah they're so good at enhancing
it's like the there's a lot of visual
storytelling but there's also a lot of
visual energy and it's all packed into
that animation it's like they're good at
packing frames with information but also
making them really visceral and
transportive and expressive and so you
really do
yeah like i i get what you mean this
does feel like you're just being sucked
in and transported to a whole other
world for 45 minutes
and you come back to real and you're
like i swear i could have touched it you
know
it felt just so real intense and i think
like in terms of animation and
storytelling between the three episodes
this one easily coalesced the best
like it's just a strong fusion of energy
throughout what exactly the science
magic people create in that moment
that's where i was like what what did
they crack exactly i i kind of missed
the mark on that i kind of wish i was
watching this with subtitles just
because it usually helps me keep up with
because as long as i get so pulled into
like a detail of a drawing it happens
sometimes i watch animation i get so
sucked into the detail of certain
moments where i'm like wow that
background looks like an oil painting oh
what did they say
that happens to me
yeah for sure it's like it's like
walking through a haunted house and
trying to enjoy all the set decorations
but also not get held up yeah yeah for
sure
that's just it's just so much
what did they create but yeah uh do you
know what they did i mean the way it
read to me was mostly that they were
able to
access
magic
just generally they were able to make a
machine that's a conduit to be able to
access this magical energy
and that machine clearly
worked i don't know if they really
created something particular because it
doesn't
appear to have a function yet but it is
the sort of like oh hey we proved we can
access this and we can open up the
potential of these crystals with you
know the machine i've been experimenting
with so that is so fascinating because
that shows the joy and wonder of it
and then what violet did shows that what
happens when it's in the violet uh
powder yeah it happens when not used
well and how much destruction it can
cause which is another really wonderful
thing that happened to powder food i
already felt so sorry for it i know
it's another one of those really candy
like real world
elements where you're like yeah there's
so many things where like in their raw
form you could create a lot of
destruction and anguish but if you know
how to tap into the potential of
whatever material you can make something
really beautiful and great and i think
that's imbued throughout the characters
throughout you know the the
you know tenets of this world like magic
or whatever else or like the science
that this guy uh is clearly perfecting
with his mutant hulk creatures you know
what was going on with vander um again
it happened to me a couple of times
during the show where i'm like
[ __ ] i should have been so wrapped up at
the animation and wondering how they did
that yeah and i was like i missed a lot
was the
the what's the guy's name fun
fox fun the the bad guy's name do you
remember his name
i think it's like an s name or something
is it as an s name here hold on a second
let's just take a quick pander
zhan
is the lower city zone's a city yeah
zone is where they live oh so what's
that guy's name
uh something well evil eye all right so
yeah
but
what what went wrong with
evil eye and vander years ago because i
know what i know what happened when it
when it came to like no we need to have
peace so he started cooperating with the
other side but what
is that what led to that fight in the
water that we kept flashing to i think
that predates it because he kind of says
like even after that you know moment
that it has built this personal grudge
between us i still respected you yes
despite our our conflict so i got the
sense and maybe i missed something but i
got the sense that whatever conflict
they were in probably rooted from their
points of view on how to deal with this
tension between the you know zone and
the top side
uh and the top side's called
is
learning stuff
you know what's cool about this what's
neat about this structure oh yeah sorry
what were you saying really quick but
now i'll remember that point there's a
lot happening here i got a lot of
thoughts yeah i don't know i mean i
didn't get the sense for if there was a
very specifically fleshed out conflict
in that moment that we were privy to
other than
i think it had to do yeah just with
their ideologies on how to handle their
conflict with uh piltover and then
you know that that predates the moment
where uh vander's like i'm gonna try and
strike a deal
admittedly the
the
all the stuff with the underworld
is so
enormously like
encapsulating and gritty and just sucks
you in and it's beautiful
and
dark and desolate
but just so rich
that sometimes when you cut back to
what's going on in piltover i'm not as
into it
like the science i'm like it's hard
because i'm like it's the other stuff is
just so freaking grippy yeah yeah
and then we come back and it was like
dark and violent yeah yeah and we're
like this is a lower stakes i mean you
know you might get exiled from your
community or whatever but you know i
mean they're not like
this isn't the part where we're
overthrowing [ __ ] and monsters are
hulking out like you know you might
cause some destruction with your work
and all that but mostly you're dealing
with more of a political situation the
camera tracking in this show is so solid
even like the littlest shots like when
when violet is upside down and then she
turns over
like when she's caught underneath the
rubble yeah just this like it's like a
fincher david fincher shot it just like
it's just such a subtle little move to
the right it's not like a
roller do it you know it's just like
where you feel like you're turning with
them and they do that with a lot of the
action it's like they follow their
movements so much yeah it's like a
cutscene it's like a video game cutscene
that's what i i would like in what i'm
watching a lot of the time is i'm
watching just brilliant video game cut
scenes but with a different animation
flourish to it to make you feel like
you're watching a video game or why am i
not just playing a video game you know
especially that trap because yeah you
like i've watched certain other things
where it's like oh it's one of those cgi
resident evil that's for those of you
who are like why aren't you playing
i'm just gonna play this yeah whereas
this is
so very much a show and a visual story
and yeah it's like you can tell that
there are those sensibilities
but i think it's it's twofold it's like
you have it in the little subtleties of
how they use the camera to make it feel
like there's a camera operator yeah who
is making choices and it's also the way
in which they imbue all of the
characters with these mannerisms that
are so subtle and so
human that's why i like and it's a
classic disney hand-drawn enemy yeah
because there's so much body language
and expression in their faces you know
what this felt like
this show feels like it it it feels like
that doctor strange episode of what if
but all the time
yeah yeah for sure especially this one
this had a lot where i was like wow look
at fantasia
yeah yeah and i think as far as the like
recent animated series have gone like
this has some of my favorite use of the
medium just because even with what if
i'm like i can tell they didn't
spare no expense to make this happen
whereas this show it feels like they
absolutely spared no expense they're
like we're going to make this
breathe both as a 3d piece but as a
thing that looks completely
authentically like it was painted by
hand that really has this distinct art
style but that has almost no seams or
edges in terms of
you know a budgetary limitation or
production limitation it is fully
immersive in that way where i'm like
this is some of the most impressive
animation recently i've seen because i
while i think this is probably all done
on computers it really feels tangible
and it really feels like they brought
you know animated storytelling and mixed
in with video game storytelling and that
kind of energy and then they took a lot
of cues from actual cinema and there's
just so much wrapped into the the
package it's delivered in that it feels
like there's
way more written not to like slag
various other animated series that have
come out recently because you know that
the animation isn't
everything uh but it is like next level
on this show at least for my experience
the animation is merely a a
major complement towards the
storytelling like the
the all the great animations great
animation but uh they can you can get
numb to that if the story's boring still
yeah
yeah and like the this this in terms of
just filmmaking this particular episode
has such a solid grip on on tension
and
tugging on your emotions like the way
they would cut around to
the immediacy
of these the insane ticking clock
situations throughout this whole episode
reminding me of like the best work of
christopher nolan when he's when he's
cutting around to
like here's what's going on here here
here we keep cutting between the three
and it's only helping to escalate into
this big bubble of of chaos and
situation and you know uh we don't know
how who's gonna win because like vander
gets kidnapped i thought he was killed
if anderson
at the beginning bam and then as we're
going through this powder's following
them these kids show up they're breaking
them out violet you know locks up you
know with the whatever those gauntlet
gloves are whatever yeah yeah the vander
hulk hands yeah and then she's like
messing over cool we're gonna win it was
a badass fight awesome as hell bam
zombie dude comes in
okay are they gonna get away
then you get the sense like
powder is gonna save the powder doesn't
save the day uh and then they're going
to go fight vander is going to get in
there he's going to take he's going to
take vengeance and stop this it looks
like vanda is going to die banner's not
dead
or breaks them out oh my god powder
thought she did a great thing powders
powders
destroyed internally and now she's with
the now she's with silko yeah you know
like the way they tug on your emotions
and have you not it was so unpredictable
to the point that everything i was
predicting just kept getting wrong by
the second to the very last frame i was
wrong
um yeah that this was brilliant
absolutely brilliant like the first
episode's a wonderful introduction the
second one is a great calm before the
storm that really sets up and my point
being is that
usually a netflix show
feels
like
they are complete because i was like
this is kind of an interesting release
strategy three episodes at a time
and the netflix shows usually feel like
okay i i actually get the full picture
now because this the whole season is
done which i'm sure i'll feel that way
by the end
but it's cool what they're doing here
because i really feel like i got a
complete like
part one yeah
with these three episodes it's a full
part one full act one you know yeah i
think that it's interesting because the
each three individually so each of the
three individually thus far has
felt like its own p like there's a
certain thing about some netflix shows
where they feel very much designed to
make you binge and they have structural
elements based off that it's well worn
territory now but this one was like each
individual episode felt like its own
striking piece and yet
being at the end of these first three
now i'm like oh yeah this feels like the
act one of a much bigger story yeah
that's the wonderful thing it's nice to
have that in a binge era exactly yeah
yeah it's like a unique
model
i mean i've never followed what if
netflix has done this before yeah but
but i think it's a really unique model
of a good splice of epis of uh one
really like a a weekly release
with a slight
binge
quality to it it's it's it's really
interesting because you could just
release this as like a hour and a half
episode
but i also get why they're divided into
three episodes instead
because it does feel like each episode
has told a very specific chapter that
maybe just slapping them together
wouldn't exactly flow
you know so it is a fascinating
structure to behold here and i i think
it's a genius
because i really feel like i completed
something and i'm waiting for like the
next set yeah and i think i i really
hope that this proves successful because
i would love to see just more
interpolations on how these shows get
out you know because it's been nice with
disney plus and stuff to return to a
time where everyone's anticipating each
week and this was very satisfying to not
have to wait so long but now i get to
enjoy the anticipation waiting for the
next three episodes yeah knowing that
they're not that far away but there's
still some time to go yeah because it
felt like when the boys did that release
strategy for amazon
it was like i get why you need to watch
the first three to get into it but it
seemed like a last-minute decision still
to go
do three once a week to keep people
watching yeah yeah exactly make sure
people don't forget too soon yeah
whereas this it feels purposeful from
the start 100
hundo p
alright guys well arcane
[ __ ] man i'm i'm so happy we're watching
this that was that was genius no that
third that final one man i was genius
they're spoiled with good tv lately
there's a little i mean there's a lot of
[ __ ] tv out there
we have
you who have you guys to come in and
tell us
what's good what's worthwhile it's good
yeah
big bang theory reactions start next
week you tend to you tend to tell it you
tend to inform us well enough to the
point where we're like okay yeah we know
uh you guys you guys tend to know what
we're like
all right guys subscribe hit that like
button click the notification bell who's
the lucky person to get up
i was thinking food a shout out of like
who is someone
who
is ambitious
she keeps trying hard and i just
want to hold
you know someone who evokes the same
emotions out of me that powder did for
this episode
that's andrew hayes oh yeah
just
this
little small fry yeah
who's just always so like energetic he's
always peppy you know he's just doing
his best
doing his best well andrew hayes just
can't pull himself out there and do what
he can
and he's just so adorable
still this little guy
his little
there's a little funny hair and you just
want to
just want to hold him
like i just want to cuddle you andrew
not on like a gay way which is totally
fine if it is a gay way
in the gayest way i want to cuddle you
the k like a father my two fathers
having a son that's the kind of gay
woman i'm talking about the beautiful
kind of beautiful thing a familial
company you don't know family yeah
that's what i want to do with you we
want to hold you we can't
take care of you
and go to pt meetings
you know
in like a southern area yeah where
they're like wow
two dads i don't know about this
and we stand up for you mm-hmm and then
you kick their asses and prove the point
that two dads is better than no dance
i'm sure that's the that's the desired
message
if you can't have a dad i guess you
[Laughter]
better buddy
[Music]